an abandoned Chinese space station is
hurtling out of control towards Earth
scientists say every continent but
Antarctica is a possible target for the
eight-ton Space Station that includes
most of the US chip readers at the
Smithsonian National Air and Space
Museum in Washington chip good morning
well good morning this is a model of
Skylab the US Space Station that fell
out of orbit in 1979 parts of it rained
down on Australia and something like
that could happen this time around but
don't put your worried face on because
the chances of actually getting hit by
debris are 10 million times smaller than
getting hit by lightning breakup
tiangong ones final moments will look
something like this
a shower of glowing debris similar to
this Japanese spacecraft that ended its
Space Odyssey in 2010 when it begins its
reentry tiangong one will be whizzing
along at four miles a second the solar
panels will shear off first then the
orbiter itself will break apart most of
the components will be incinerated and
never reached the earth but some parts
could survive creating a debris field
about four hundred miles long and 30
miles wide we won't know even the day of
the event where it's going to be exactly
bill Aylor a fellow at the Aerospace
Corporation says it's possible large
pieces of tiangong one could end up on
the ground like this 500-pound chunk of
a rocket that crashed near a Texas
farmhouse before this one came down
people said half these things don't
survive this one proved that they did
Lottie Williams is the only known person
to be hit by space debris The Oklahoman
was not hurt in the 1997 incident it
rolled off my shoulder onto the ground
and it sound metallic the European Space
Agency says about eight thousand tons of
debris is orbiting the Earth including
satellites and metal fragments leftover
from collisions and explosions George
Washington University Space expert John
Logsdon says satellites are usually
dumped into the South Pacific
once they're obsolete bottom that ocean
is full of dead satellites the problem
here is that China has lost control and
so you can't
fire retrorockets our control where it
comes down we won't have a good idea of
where the tiangong one will crash until
about a day before it happens and if you
do happen to come across it don't
breathe the vapors and don't touch it
because it could have toxic substances
Nora that sounds like a reason have on
your worried face yes there's Lottie
Williams out there who got hit back in
there I'm concerned worried face for
space junk there yep thank you again